welcome to the data science hangout and
welcome back to everyone who's been here
before and to those joining for the
first time
i'm rachel dempsey
and i think we all kind of know the
drill by now but we want to use this
time to focus on questions that are most
important to you all
so there's really no agenda for
these meetings
and everyone's welcome to join in live
or put any questions that you have in
the chat
this week we're also going to add a
slido
link into the chat so if you did want to
ask anything anonymously
that you have the opportunity to do so
as well
um and rob if you wouldn't mind
putting into that into the chat that
would be awesome
just the one i sent you on slack
is there a password that people have to
use
nope so there shouldn't be a password
they could just go there and you could
put your name there or you can choose
anonymous
but also just want to share with
everyone
at the beginning here that
we will share the recording of each
hangout on youtube so that other data
science leaders and aspiring leaders can
benefit from the discussion
but without further ado i'm joined by my
co-host for today
uh francis corrigan also known goes by
frank
director of decision intelligence at
target
and so frank joined
a few weeks ago for the first one and is
here today as our featured data science
leader
and talking with frank he's very
passionate about discovering new ways to
think about the world and
the communication of the work that that
his team does um so i'm really excited
to
hear some of your insights frank and
have the opportunity to ask you a few
questions
would you be able to kind of introduce
yourself and share a little bit about
the work that you do
yeah absolutely uh and i'll start off by
saying i am happy to take the lead on
the questions that come through the chat
this week um but i found it over the
past few weeks to be incredibly helpful
and useful hearing other people's
perspective about the work they're doing
how they're communicating their work and
some of the challenges they're facing so
by all means i'm i'm as much willing to
hear other perspectives as give you mine
uh i i work at target currently i've
been at target for almost four years now
i build and lead
let's call them data science teams
we support transportation within the
supply chain
and i
i typically default to calling
our data analysts technical problem
solvers
because effectively that's that's what
they are right we're here to solve
problems for the supply chain make
things go faster spend less money doing
it make sure that the shelves at your
local target store are full of product
um
and we just do it a little bit
differently than the operators or maybe
the other business analysts right we
have a different toolkit um and it is a
bit more technical right we we write
code we we all have no r we know python
um
we're not software engineers i'll tell
you that we try to be diligent in our
coding practices uh but
it is definitely not um
software engineering that we're doing uh
and then the other thing i'll say is we
don't shun excel or spreadsheets i think
there is uh kind of just going on that
excel is kind of old and it's over there
and right people that use excel are just
business analysts but
i mean if you're solving problems having
those those kinds of tools at your
disposal are also helpful at times right
right right time right problem uh yeah i
sometimes say that excel
or csvs are the whiteboard of data
analysis right how quickly can you
prototype an idea and communicate it
with your partners and your stakeholders
um in excel versus right trying to to
mark something i would say right the
next level is getting a notebook out and
doing it there
but ultimately maybe that gives you an
idea of how my team operates and where
we're coming from right so problem
solver so we want to solve problems we
have this technical toolkit to to do it
with
with that said what i love most about it
and why i keep doing it after right so
i'd say i've been doing this stuff uh
for about a decade past four years
at target but i love the that moment
when you are analyzing data or you're
finding insight and your perspective
just kind of changes from you thought
the world was a certain way to
wait that doesn't make sense or holy cow
right i didn't never really thought
about it that way
and i think that that goes back to when
uh so in my past i've taught a few
economics classes at the college level
and it was my favorite thing in the
world when a student would
look right have that look on their face
and say
oh yeah i never thought about it like
that right and being able to deliver
that that change of perspective was
awesome because i i truly believe that
if you can
take in multiple perspectives and really
shape an opinion or review about how the
world is and we're trying to get as
close to truth as possible you end up
making better decisions right you make
better decisions as an individual your
team makes better decisions your
stakeholders it's good for your company
it's good for the individuals and then
those good decisions compound on each
other
and you ultimately have a profitable
company or i think a better life
so my favorite part about being able to
do it at work is
i find that it's practice right for me
my team my stakeholders to use data to
think about things differently and in a
better fashion so ultimately we can
provide value for target um in my
current state but then also i i want
everyone that that i work with to be
able to use that skill on the decisions
that they make outside of work
as well in their relationships with
their finances
so on and so forth
thank you so much frank
um something that i'd love to ask you
about before some of the questions come
in is
that whole like problem formation
process and i know you said like there's
a few different ways that you go about
the delivery of that and methods that
you use
i would love to hear more about that i
think
something you had mentioned was like the
weekly newsletter or happy hours and i
love that idea
yeah so there's uh right as with
everything there's two hands so on one
hand if you're a data or data science
team you can
sit there
right you consider your desk look at the
backlog figure out when requests come in
you need this data pulled or you need
this analysis done or need this question
answered
on the other hand
there is a state where
um
you want to be thinking creatively and
really trying as best as possible to
find the unknown unknowns
and try to tackle those because if you
can find some of those and bring those
to the business that becomes the truth
in my opinion the true unlock um and in
in order to do that you you need a
little bit of credibility or maybe a lot
of credibility um and you need ways to
for yourself to get more creative so two
of the ways that that i try to do that
um
in in my
daily life in my line of work are
my stakeholders in operations have
weekly business reviews or wbrs i make
sure that i attend those wbrs so i can
listen to
the supply chain operators or the
business analysts talk about the
problems they are seeing in their
business because that can give me a
spark of oh man i know i'm reading this
book on regression maybe i can connect
in some of the methods i'm learning over
there with some of the problems i'm
hearing about on this call
and then if i'm able to ask questions
within those wbrs
then people say oh man frank shows up or
frank's team shows up and they always
ask really good questions and if people
think right doesn't have to be an answer
if they think that you can ask good
questions and make them think about
something differently right they're
going to invite you back
and then the second thing that i do is i
i write a biweekly newsletter and it is
i do a few things and i've experimented
a few ways but ultimately what i'm
trying to do is write about the industry
and the state of the supply chain
industry connect that in with data
analysis methods and do it in a way that
is uh educational uh so anyone can read
it whether you're a supply chain
operator or whether you're a data
analyst and you can get value out of it
because you're kind of
creating that bridge between the
technical
methods and then
how that applies to the problems you are
solving
and i do those two things because at the
end of the day when i bring a solution
or my team brings a solution to our
stakeholders
right i want them to listen right
because if they don't listen they're
going to get implemented right and by
doing this i i basically integrate me
and my team into the broader objectives
that we're trying to to work on um and
we
create an environment and a platform
where you have
uh
both people listening and and talking
and then it goes back and forth both
ways that's great and and how do people
find out about the newsletter how did
you start that
is it mostly are there like people
interested in our or how do you share it
yeah absolutely
it's a great question when i when i
originally started doing it at target it
was totally grassroots um i put
everybody that i had on the email
distribution it was all uh it wasn't bcc
at first right i just put everybody out
there and at the beginning of the letter
i would say hey this is why i'm doing
this if anybody else wants to be
included on this newsletter that you
don't see their name out there pass it
along and if they if they want to be on
it they need to ask me and i actually
made it
i had a sort of a strict policy because
i really wanted people that were
interested in it so unless you
explicitly asked me via email or called
me up and said hey can i get on your
newsletter distribution i wouldn't add
people so i never added people just
because i thought they would be
interested i wanted to be a total pull
system
and it worked really well and then i
created a large distribution and now i
have
i
it's like distributions within
distributions of teams so i think
there's somewhere close to 200 people
on my
my weekly distribution and it's really
word of mouth
that that it keeps growing
that's really cool
i see a few questions are coming through
on the slido as well okay
so there's one question there that says
what is the divide between a business
analyst and a data scientist in your
eyes
yeah uh awesome question so
concentric circles of course but i'll
explain it one way and there's probably
other ways to think about this as well
in my eyes the business analyst is there
every day
trying to respond to the questions at
hand for the day or the week
or maybe the two weeks
most of the stuff that they are working
on is going to be
relatively one-off right hey can you
help me figure out this carrier problem
this week can you help me figure out why
a vendor isn't shipping on time this
week
and then
those
insights or those discoveries ultimately
we want to be able to do that in a
repeat fashion so i kind of see that's
where the technical problem solvers can
bring their
more technical skills in and say oh
that's great that we found that let's do
that over and over again
so right business analysts more ad hoc
one-offs and then the technical problem
solvers we're trying to scale it up and
make it repeatable
with that said
the technical problem solvers also
sometimes are working on ad hoc but
maybe we need to figure out how many
yard spaces do we need in our yards
because we're going to have the highest
volumes that target has ever pushed
through our supply chain network this
fall
should we get additional off-site yard
space at some yards so
yeah again concentric circles but that's
a little bit of the differentiation that
i see
great thank you
um i
uh kevon and i know i pronounce your
name differently every time so if you
wouldn't mind introducing yourself and
and asking that question i i see you put
one on slido
um yeah it's uh it's pronounced caven um
like as if you were to take the l out of
calvin
um thank you of course um
yeah i was wondering what your most
unique problem you have had to solve on
your team slash in your in your industry
most unique problem
i think that
one of the
so
at one point at target i was working in
our last mile delivery space so while
small transportation we worked a lot
with ups and fedex
and one of the more unique things that
target has done in the past few years is
starting to deliver a lot of our last
mile ecommerce packages from our stores
and as part of that you can imagine that
ups and fedex in their last mile
delivery networks weren't used to doing
or picking out two three 400 packages
from a bunch of different locations
throughout a certain geographic network
they were very used to there's a
distribution center there's a big truck
here we need to move it from here to
your distribution center and then you
deliver all those packages from there so
this was kind of a new thing not just
for for target as a huge retailer but
also for our carrier partners that we
work with and i got to really work on
the forefront of that um i don't i don't
know if it is fortunate or unfortunate
right some days are whenever you're
working on something new you have
frustrating days and some days you have
huge wins
um so i'd say that was that was a pretty
unique experience in terms of figuring
out uh especially in supply chain
sometimes we're dealing with a lot of
different systems we're dealing with a
lot of different human behavior
and we target has eighteen hundred plus
stores around the country so
and we were shipping out of most of
those stores so you can imagine all
those stores operating sort of in their
own ecosystem but trying to solve
problems of making sure those packages
got onto those trucks the visibility of
saying are those packages getting
packed on time all the way are they
getting picked up by the carrier on time
are they making it to the carriage
facility on time trying to string all of
that data together which my team was
responsible for and then trying to
understand how do we fill in the missing
pieces that we know aren't there and
we're not going to have a technology
solution to see that for a year down the
road
i would say that's
the thing that comes to mind is probably
the more unique challenge
that i've had the pleasure of working on
thank you
seth i see you have a question that you
entered in as well
and i
think maybe we copied over wrong because
it looks very similar to the one that we
asked before
so tyler just want to confirm
so let me
double check on that and i'll jump to
the next question rob you had asked
what's the biggest mistake you've made
in your role and and what did you learn
from this mistake
uh i saw that one um so that's been
brewing in the back of my brain
uh
we all have a lot of challenges that we
face um the thing that comes to mind for
me is
if you
if you cannot find and hire the right
people um
your job is going to be that much harder
as a leader as a manager so when i think
about
what the most important thing that i
have to do when i'm running a team is
identifying the right talent
and then trying to convince them to come
on to the team
uh in terms of mistakes there are people
that that i've had on my team and right
they've they've done great and they've
come onto the team uh they've onboarded
they've gone through
a ton of value and then left but there's
people who have come on team and
probably realize this isn't the right
place for them
but
what i'm really getting to is when i
think about the the right talent what
does that mean
i heavily index on behaviors
um and i always think that if you can
find individuals that have the right
behaviors
then the outcomes are going to follow
from that so when i think about
behaviors
folks that are bold and intellectually
curious right they they have a hard time
sleeping if they can't go find an answer
or come up with a process to go find an
answer
that's really huge uh i find extreme
ownership to be another winning behavior
uh i want people on the team who are
going to show up and say oh man you know
that problem happened that's on me i
should have done something differently
even when it's not on them right like
everyone else in the room looks at them
and says like that that's definitely not
on you right there's nothing you could
have done differently
but just having that attitude of saying
right i i could change something i do
next time and that sense of control is
really big um and then also i always
talk about learning frameworks i think
that the the people on my team um should
be learning
constantly and not just right it's not
just hey i have this this project i have
to learn
uh a new forecasting skill i think it is
really important for all people that
work in the data industry to just be
constantly learning and reading because
that's right i referenced the unknown
unknowns before i feel like that's how
you
you can ultimately find those
you'll be pummeled with business
problems all day long
but it's the people who are kind of
going outside of the normal day and
trying to get
other information
and bring that back to those problems
who really thrive
so in terms of mistakes uh no no
particular tm comes to mind but there's
there's been a lot of learning over the
past 10 years that i have been hiring
people and building teams um to get to a
point where i'm like oh yeah it is
behaviors when i go into an interview
with with a potential team member
i'm going to index on trying to figure
out what their behaviors are and how
they will will fit into the team
do you think some of those behaviors are
something that you can help teach them
or it's something that they kind of have
to come
to the role with
uh
let's say 50 50.
yeah there's there's definitely things
that you can learn
but some things
seem to be intrinsic a little bit or
maybe have learned over a long period of
time
so like if it's something that you can
learn over a three year period that's a
long runway
yeah
sup i'm seeing the right question from
from you now um would you want to expand
a bit on the question regarding
onboarding
yeah sure it's a a nice
nice tangent considering you're already
kind of talking about onboarding
i was just kind of wondering i mean uh
as you're as you're speaking about
hiring and and you know finding the
right talent part of that is you know
once you do hire is onboarding you have
these newsletters like what's your
process for getting people kind of up
and running and obviously contributing
in the manner that you hired them for
but also kind of being in sync with the
rest of the team with
you know
everything else
yeah for sure um
so there are
i'd say the two components that i get
new team members to focus on most
heavily the first is developing
relationships so there's a lot of gets
no use at target um
you come work at target you see those
all over your calendar um whether
whether i've been here for a few years
because right we have new people coming
on um and especially if it's your first
month enroll but because i um i do index
heavily on the relationship aspect
because i think the relationship will
help facilitate communication i say
let's make sure that you are
getting to know our stakeholders better
and our partners so i'll set up a lot of
those make sure those coffees are
happening
and then on the technical side uh
we have
the the technical tools and the
processes that we use it's not
incredibly diverse right we do use r and
python i know some shops who are
relatively smaller will just be a an r
shop or a python shop but we have a
relatively small set of tools that we
use so
i do have team members and that i think
i always had on any team that i built
who are
very inclined to teach other people what
they know
so you know who those people are in your
team and you say hey this is your
partner for the first month right new
team member this is your partner for the
first month they're going to show you
the tools that you need to know where
the data is that that you need to know
and then they'll also show you what we
don't have today because we do have
limitations in our capabilities so and
then when i check in something i do
especially if it's a relatively new
right if we have someone coming out of
school and it is uh their first job or
their their second job they have only
been in workforce for a year i'll make
sure to have a right personally even if
um right i have senior managers under me
but um
if they're coming out i'll make sure to
have a 15-minute check-in with them
every day right especially in virtual
world
they might feel a little bit lost so
i'll have a 15-minute check-in every day
and kind of say hey who are you meeting
what do you think did you did you like
them do
would you have another coffee with them
but then also hey what what technical
skills or what what data set do you
learn about today just to keep us
aligned
great thank you this kind of this
question kind of goes back to what we
were just talking about before about
some of the behavioral skills
but how do you actually interview
candidates for
those qualities like do you use
assignments as part of an interview
process as well
uh so personally i've not used
assignments um there's
two
um two different ways so let me talk
about the two different ways so the
first is i
um i spent
uh a year working at wayfair and i think
this is a habit i picked up from wayfair
because the any if you've ever gone
interviewed a wafer you've probably been
through a case question or a few case
questions because they love that there
and i picked up the habit there and i
feel like
uh working with a potential candidate no
matter what level just working through a
case question trying to solve a problem
together and right you
either do it on the whiteboard or
you just have a piece of paper and then
you can show each other what you're
writing down
you can
identify a considerable amount of
behavior and attitudes through doing
that exercise with each other
um and then also follow-up questions is
huge in the interview right so there's
always a let me ask you the first
question uh and then right if the
candidate gives you an answer um always
have a follow-up question because i find
right if you can go a level deeper
that's kind of the more revealing
segment
so case questions i'd say are number one
number two um
we
i had a partner um that
would have he he had a uh linear
regression interview question and it
would be hey do you know arduino python
people that could do this in excel great
i don't think anyone ever tried to do an
excel but it was a relatively basic
linear build a linear regression
question um and then go through it and
talk through the ah-ha's oh there's
heteroskedasticity
in in the model that that's going to
throw us off
and have candidates run through that and
you can kind of see how they think
um and it really
really wasn't about can you do the code
right can you call the problem it was
more about how they think and how they
try to
to navigate around the problem at hand
and i think that kind of brought out
some of those behaviors that i had
mentioned before
going through that process
just talking about interviewing like
that makes me a little bit nervous
um he's talking about interviewing on
the sporo makes me think i probably have
to rethink some of my methods now
i see there's an anonymous question on
the slido frank
talking about the newsletter so you
mentioned you only add people once they
express clear interest
do you feel it's also important to
motivate non-data scientists to see the
light
absolutely
yeah and don't get me wrong it's not
like i don't advertise at all
i've said a few times i am uh
very adamant about making sure i am
looked in with my stakeholders making
sure i'm looking with supply chain
operators and i'm always alluding to the
newsletter that i write right so i'll
always throw that into a conversation
here or there um and the the curious
folks will say wait what are you talking
about what what newsletter you're
talking about um and i'll call it i
won't call it necessarily a um
a data analytics newsletter i'll call it
all right
my supply chain newsletter right or my
supply chain updates newsletter and so
there's a little bit of selling that i
do here and there um but yeah getting
getting both perspectives is is super
important
and to be
honest i i haven't done
i haven't done the counts
but i would say that
if you took my distribution list of
upward of 200 people for the newsletter
that i'm writing now i would say it's
about 50 50 in terms of supply chain
operators and inventory analysts making
right making those decisions and then
more technical data science
technical problem solver roles
i feel like that's something that can
apply to any role as well because i'm
thinking about like the meetups and
hangouts and things that i help organize
it'd be helpful probably to make a
newsletter for our own team to say like
this what's what's going on too yeah
hugh i i see you put a question into the
chat um would you want to introduce
yourself and ask that life
sure hey i'm uh hugh walch i'm a
management analyst with the va
i'm just curious if you have any
particular podcasts or youtube channels
or blogs that you follow to keep up
with your
uh with your knowledge or discover new
skills
yes
so i'm always looking for new resources
yeah well let's see if i have anything
new for you maybe it's all just just
redundant but um
uh yeah so every morning uh right we
used to commute so i used to be a
podcaster on the commute but now um i
have a two-year-old
labradoodle and i walk him every morning
we go out for a walk so i listen to
podcasts uh the ones that i have on my
radar now i'll give you three so number
one
is
the knowledge project by shane parrish
which is more mental model decision
making
it's a big one
the freakonomics
uh network of podcasts so both free
economics people i mostly admire because
again right i think that's all about
asking great questions
ultimately you want to get data and
answer those questions but i find those
those podcasts get me into a great
mindset to ask good questions and then
the most um
data e podcast i listen to right now a
few weeks i discovered um learning
bayesian statistics
yeah lbs learning learning daisy and
statistics um which is
really nerdy and pretty technical but uh
i've always right i am not there yet by
no means but i've always wanted to be a
bayesian uh so i'm trying to get there
by immersing myself in the terminology
and the frameworks and uh going a little
bit deeper
and that one's a a ton of fun um
the way that that the uh creator does it
awesome thank you
i'm curious if there's any others that
everyone else would want to recommend as
well
there's got to be one there's kind of
i see mike put not so standard
deviations in the chat there
this is daniel uh i'm about to jump but
i i just started listening to uh data
skeptic
which i find good
cool
i would uh
if you if you just started listening to
it daniel i would recommend you go back
to the beginning i like i thought his
first kyle's first two seasons were
fantastic
all of it's good but the first two were
um yeah i couldn't get enough of it
yeah the the reason i started listening
to it was a lot of uh my problems are
kind of like time series-esque uh and i
think his latest like season
covers time series so that's kind of how
i first got connected to it makes sense
cool well if there are others feel free
to put them in the chat too it'd be cool
to put a list of them down
um
i see mike you asked the question on and
slido do you want to ask that one live
sure i was busy adding podcasts to my
podcast
um
yeah i'm interested in whether your
colleagues are working off consistent
versions of tools
you know so do you say okay everyone is
now an r4 or 4-1
and everyone's got same version same set
of packages same versions of packages i
mean how do you how do you manage that
when you're
like in a small group
um i'll be honest and so i'll start i'll
start off with a no answer and then i'll
back out from there so no
uh but i uh
the reason that we're we're almost being
forced to be better about it because we
target is developing better tools
uh two maybe two weeks ago i mentioned
that um
we have a
team called dataminer and dataminer is
now producing uh hosted versions of our
studio hosted notebooks both in python
and r so we are that is helping us to
align um our versions and right so at
any given time people are creating new
new new notebooks new new scripts um
it's kind of forcing us and
that is looped in with our with our
github
um repositories so that is
is kind of a lot like forcing us to
align which i think is the purpose of
having great data tools right if you
have great data tools they kind of force
you like they don't allow you to have
bad habits
and if you have anything that you can
teach me like i'm all yours on this one
well i i i wrestle with this constantly
um i work in pharma we're regulated
and it worries the heck out of me what
versions of things people have on their
desktops
right and we have kind of like a
separate
um instance of r which is the kind of
fully qualified take you know documented
sdlc
stamped controlled version
um but
still
i know that colleagues are going to
develop code on their desktops and then
when it breaks they're going to come to
me as resident our geek and go hey mike
why is this broken
and and you know my my kind of gut
reaction is burn it all down get the
standard version
retry and then if it's still broken i'll
help you um
but it that kind of
battle of reproducibility
you know managing versions and and you
know even just trying to help colleagues
is super hard
if if you can't guarantee what they're
using
um
and actually it's something that i i'm
wrestling with right at the minute um
i believe it yeah so again when we
these hosted products that we have that
stuff is all built in we can just share
that stuff with each other
yeah yeah
uh anyone else
oh sorry again
the other thing i'll mention is that um
you mentioned you're in healthcare oh
your pharmaceuticals and it's right very
regulated um
i'm in supply chain most of the stuff we
do at supply chain in retail
most of the stuff we do is not food
related uh
so
we are
nowhere near the level of regulation uh
dealing with regulation that you are
yeah i mean it it
is
it's more intense
other ends of the business right
um
but still
if we're submitting
anything to the fda
we want to be really sure
you know that
not just that we can stand behind what
people have done but we could reproduce
it time and time and time again
and you know occasionally it does happen
they come back you know five years ten
years later and go you know you did that
model well can you just explain this to
us or could you look at this thing for
us and so we have to be ready to kind of
go okay roll back
um so that's that's definitely a
challenge
yeah uh thinking about can i reproduce
these results from this model five years
from now
if you can reproduce it six months from
now you're doing really well
and a similar note um
i'm curious what a lot of teams are
doing to manage different r packages too
or like how do you determine which ones
people can use across
that that's a good question
um i used to
say to colleagues that okay there's a
kind of shopping list of packages that
we roll out so we we kind of said
here's an officially supported version
of r
and with that comes this set
right because that set is also going to
be aligned to that version of our
up on our regulated qualified instance
so if you develop with that set we know
you'll get it to run on our production
system
um
but
we've
that was a
that was horrible to maintain because it
was off it was about a thousand packages
you know if you go for number packages
plus all their dependencies
and so if you're trying to push a
thousand packages to someone on their
first install it takes a while and b
they're gonna be if it breaks then
you've got a lot of mopping up to do
um so now i've kind of
we're switching over to supporting um
our studio server pro
and we're saying okay this is where you
you do your development work if you want
to work on your desktop
here's the version that we're supporting
and here's a kind of get you started set
and you know we get that from our studio
package manager
um
but we're then kind of saying look your
desktop is just a
sandbox you know try stuff out
if it works great if it doesn't work
whatever
and if you get into a complete mess then
just
you know blow all the way and start
again
um we are tiptoeing into using
package or at least i'm trying to kind
of persuade colleagues to to go down
that route um so that at least
over and above that standard set if they
get something for a little project over
here
then i know that they've got a kind of
reproducible little environment
for that project
people putting that one in the chat too
but
the
real problem is that i have no control
over what people do
so they'll just sit there and go install
dot packages
and i'm like well where did you get that
from
you know what what snapshot of karana
you're running i don't know where did it
go i don't know
and then they'll go it doesn't work mike
and i'm like oh yeah of course it
doesn't work
and then you've got to try and back out
of that and that's that's where it gets
tricky because i think
some some people like there's a
uh a spectrum of folks from the folks
who really know what they're doing and
are careful and manage it well and can
pick
unpick things when they go wrong and
then there's the folks at the other end
who really don't care they just want to
get work done
and then and it's kind of in the middle
you know the folks down this end will
take what you give them and will do what
they need and most of the time they'll
get away with it it's the folks in the
middle who kind of just you know tinker
and then things break and it that's
that's the hard one
to support
are they left with a slightly better
installation and you know you're not
sure why that thing isn't working
anymore
i'm just curious for everyone here too
if there's ways to kind of teach that
like coding best practices like from
from the get-go or if people do that
those kind of good hygiene practices
there was there was uh actually just
yesterday there was a talk from um greg
wilson
can you guys hear me
yes i can okay and uh it was about
actually design patterns it was really
good talking it's gonna give it again
next month and if you join you have to
pay but it's all going to the donations
for a charity that you chose and he
talked a lot about this they thought
about the challenge that
expert developers
and any language
they write at a higher level of
abstraction and novice developers the
gap is just too big because the novice
literally cannot read that because
they're not at that level of abstraction
so bridging this gap is a huge challenge
and uh he said actually there isn't
really a solution there but i think a
lot of that comes from learning by
example and mentoring and and having
somebody show you and explain that but i
don't think there's really
one thing he mentioned there's really no
clear resource yet i think he was kind
of trying to get people to try and
author that
that helps people bridge this gap right
like you've got advanced high level
stuff and then you've got like a lot a
lot of really basic stuff but there's
nobody that's really showing you how to
refactor and go from or very few to
really go from the basic to the to the
advanced and why you would really want
to do that
so that's actually a huge a huge gap in
the in the learning
i think
rick would you um thank you for sharing
that would you be able to share the link
to that in the chat i actually i have i
have the the slide open because i was
still making notes on it it was really
good um but he's still developing it so
he's gonna give if you if you join if
you're um uh linked with him on linkedin
he he puts his updates there or i guess
also on on twitter um i'll put it in the
i'll put in the chat here so this is
these are the slides from the
presentation
and he talks a little bit um
i i can't remember exactly where it is
where he talks about the abstractions
and and going to higher level stuff but
it's inside there and he'll give the
talk again in about one month if you
want to join it so it's it's a work in
progress and once he's finished he'll
make a video and then release a webinar
or a video on youtube or something where
you'll see his comments great
thank you
so this may shift gears a little bit but
i see an anonymous question that that
came in but
it's my leaders always refer to our bi
tools when asked about data science a
cringe as a shiny programmer do you
consider bi data science why or or why
not
i uh so
personally i i would say yes
um i would say it's a step in the data
science process i
haven't been able to understand why data
science is taken as
the building predictive models um
as and then like there's the bi before
that because
how do you build good predictive models
if you can't do feature engineering and
where does good feature engineering come
from
to me that comes from the bi stuff right
exploring your data visually trying to
understand the real in in the real world
how did that data get created
um
we could probably right someone could
probably disagree with me and say well
you know like some of this deep learning
stuff and the neural networks that are
that are being created you can just feed
it a bunch of data and then it gives you
good pretty good predictions
but i don't know at least in my world a
lot of it is you got to know your data
you got to know the process through what
it's created you gotta know what it's
telling you and what it what it can't
tell you before you build um
a good model so that's my opinion
if anyone else feels free to
or wants to jump in on that too if i
don't want to kind of shift gears too
quickly on on certain topics if people
want to add anything else
uh just for clarification i think is the
interpretation like bi tools like power
bi or just like other business
intelligence
tools
it was
an anonymous question but just as
general um business intelligence
tools
i personally like it i think it's just
like how people a lot of people use
excel and we were talking about this
earlier like it's it's an important tool
and it's important for a lot of people
as a
stepping stone um into more powerful
tools and it's like yeah again the
whiteboard of data science and it has
its definite uses
in the data science world so
yeah it's it's not it's definitely like
still data science and it's definitely
still a useful tool um for people who
enjoy it so like
not everybody speaks english some people
speak spanish and people who
know how to speak spanish will still use
still be speaking spanish even if
they're not bilingual
so
yeah i think i think it's important for
people who are comfortable in bi to keep
on using bi
curious
what the group thinks about situations
maybe where
the
business decision makers are insisting
on
someone using you know the data science
team using bi tools only
does you guys come across that and how
do you respond to that because that
seems to be a thread like why do you
want to use
these sets of tools when we've already
invested a lot in
insert you know the bi tool of choice
uh from my perspective the only time
that i run into that is in the the
delivery or the output
right they want output to be
standardized
from one platform or one one view
because right and standardization has
its value right so
being familiar with you open your phone
or you're opening your laptop i'm going
to take a look at the reports of the
month of the week it is helpful for
leaders across
right different teams and different
parts of the company to have a common
view so
to me i can understand
that component to a degree i i haven't
run across like you need to do the
analysis with
this
certain set
with this tool or these certain sets of
tools anybody else
no one else is blind three more seconds
no one else is bumping up against this
hey so this is hugh again we're this is
kind of what we're actively living right
now
um you know we've got certain officially
blessed
things that don't quite meet all of our
needs we're having to justify why we
want to go to
alternatives and uh one of the things
that's really helped us out with our
leadership
uh is showing value early you know
getting something that can't be done in
another way or is not easily done
uh and the resources we're given and
then taking that and say hey here's how
we can add value uh using these open
source tools that don't cost us anything
and that's usually kind of the big hook
right there is this cost us nothing
other than our time to build
but i will say it's still an uphill
battle
and something that i've seen i'm new to
my company but
we're using things like power bi to do a
lot more complex
data cleaning and data manipulation and
to me
that's not what power bi is built for
you're not you need to you need to pull
that data out run it through r you need
to run through python whatever it may be
doesn't matter just not in power bi
because you're gonna slow your whole
process down you're gonna you're gonna
bog down i mean whatever server you're
running that stuff on so it's
uh that's been our struggle or from what
i've seen is trying to get them out of
the
using the tool for the incorrect
task basically
i've done something similar where i've
i've done both like the cleaning in bi
for like power bi and in r and then i've
just shown like my managers like here's
the difference and they make their
decision and they usually like
focus on whatever's faster
so
yeah if there are two decisions and if
you have the time then like yeah just
making
both or making both
both the r version and the power bi
version and then yeah just seeing how
they like either of those solutions
[Music]
hugh i'm curious
you mentioned building something that
shows something
i can really only do this or do it well
using the tool of choice for you
can you give an example of what
something like that would be
sure um
try and be brief a lot of things we
build here
are specifically for our c-suite
leadership but they need to be able to
get that 30 000 foot view
uh and then on demand drill down into
okay this is what i need to see if we
identify a problem i need to get to that
mid-level information and then hand it
off in the same tool to front-line
leadership to actually address the
operational issues uh
i've
experienced with tableau used that for a
lot i've used power bi a bit
personally to my frustration
and i haven't run into anything that
lets you take
in one cohesive package go from very
very high level down through all the
different stages
to get to a very granular level
with
as much user friendliness as you can
build into some of the things we do
with the things we build in our
thanks
you unless that people have anything
else to to add to this this thread i see
there are a few other questions
that came in too and
rick one
that you just put in around different
differentiating between analytical
thinking and critical thinking skills
would you want to expand a bit on that
question
uh i guess i'm thinking about it because
there was um
somebody just posted on linkedin a
couple days ago
um when somebody that's uh i can't
remember who was somebody somebody that
does things on uh data literacy and
things like this and then he he posted
uh i guess to try and gauge responses
from his audience it was what um
what what do you do
to develop critical thinking skills but
he didn't really define what he meant by
critical thinking skills and i realized
i have my
definition that i understand it and i
put that into my own mental models that
it makes sense and i think it makes
really good sense for me but then i
realized that actually these people had
a lot of different ideas so his
suggestion to develop critical thinking
skills was to
[Music]
be by yourself for a long time i think
and i was like
i think you can develop meditation
skills and i think you can maybe develop
creativity skills uh i mean i i like to
think a lot when but i mean
maybe that's pretty critical thinking
skills about i just think of questions
and make connections when i'm just
thinking by myself and it's a lot of fun
but i think that doesn't necessarily
just sitting there thinking doesn't
actually necessarily develop those
skills
so the question is um how do you define
the difference between agricultural and
critical thinking because those terms
get tossed around a lot and i think
they're poorly understood or defined and
is that important for you and how do you
how do you actually um
evaluate that
man uh okay so
um when i think about critical thinking
skills i think that is
in my in my mind i
i layer in a component of
curiosity and drive because i think
about my bicycle is broken right i'm
gonna figure out what's wrong with my
bicycle you try something that didn't
work then
it takes you a second to think man what
else could it be right uh well it could
even be a flat tire right one of the
reasons my tire went flat and
i look at the the tube and this is the
reason why the tubing flat's broken in
certain way
the amount of critical thinking that
goes into that will hopefully lead you
to not inflate your tire as much next
time you go riding maybe you had to do
some some research on the web or maybe
you had a
great friend tell you like oh if you
over inflate your tire it's going to
press down too much
on like too much pressure when you roll
over a rock and right it's going to
pinch your tube and
likely to get a hole um to me like going
through all those steps is critical
thinking right so it applies to a ton of
problems that we face in our daily lives
and in work
i will contrast that with analytical
thinking which is the ability
or the tendency to apply um these
quantitative methods to try to help
answer your question
uh or or solve your problem so the one
thing that jumped to my mind was
in our space we are trying to figure out
there's different types of distribution
centers um all around the country
target has distribution centers we have
a bunch of trucks in our distribution
centers
all the trailers and trucks in our
let's call them trailers all the
trailers in our yards are in different
statuses right some have product on them
that needs to be unloaded to the dc some
are being loaded so that they can go
deliver to the stores there are some
that are
we can't use because they need
maintenance on them right and there's
this question
how much in each yard should there be of
certain types of trailers right because
then once one of those types goes out of
threshold
you can say hey dc this is getting too
high like we got to bring that down we
got to work this we got to get these out
of the yard things like that um
analytically how could you try to solve
that mathematically right and to me
someone who's
someone who's thinking really
analytically can say like oh well we can
build a discrete event simulation model
um and try to figure out how the trucks
are moving around and and once we get to
a point where a certain number of
trailers over over x that's your
threshold number there
because then we have problems
i feel like that is sort of
uh if you were to read a textbook right
that's that's what you're gonna get to
me analytical thinking goes beyond that
and that's where you start connecting
other dots so someone says oh what if we
try to use a decision tree to say like
there's a problem in the yard when the
types of trailers gets to whatever
number and then you think about your top
layer and then it splits right and then
it splits again what are those split
numbers of your decision tree could
those be your threshold numbers
and the answer is i rate
[Music]
i would say that that's creative
thinking you're you're thinking beyond
the standard textbook
how can i use a tool that wasn't meant
for this purpose but can handle that
kind of data and i can and it works and
it's going to be valid all the
assumptions are met and it's going to be
about result but actually nobody's going
to really think about doing that and i
was obviously that's another couple
which is the the creative thinking um
and top of that which i guess is part of
the analytical
uh would you agree with my critical
thinking assessment
yeah i think i i the way the way that i
i started to
understand to put into a mental model
for myself was that critical thinking is
kind of like what you described it think
about like all the ways that can go
wrong and you're really thinking about
the interaction
and all the different components fit
together and when you pull this lever
how does it affect the rest of and all
the different inputs and all the
different pieces working together um and
so it's really a systems thinking it's a
big picture approach and the analytical
i would agree with what you said um
aside from the the creativity part the
analytical is uh is reductionist
thinking which is how many many people
are taught to think and are taught in
universities and are taught when they
learn programming or data science you
break something down to its component
parts and then you just focus on
understanding this one little tiny thing
right like i'm a biologist and you study
this one gene
and that's it like back in the good old
days you would have somebody study a
single protein for 40 years and that was
a long time ago right so they would like
to dissect that protein for everything
that they could possibly do um and then
kind of evolve and say well we want to
go back and understand how that protein
works in the whole the whole kind of
system so then i put that on critical
thinking is the big picture systems
thinking and analytical thinking is the
reductionist component pieces and the
issue with that i realized with with
critical thinking is that
we learn and we're taught and we live in
a society that's very much focused on
analytical thinking right like like i
think like vitamins right vitamins is
another protein you can just take
vitamin c you can just take some protein
you can rub dna on your skin and it's
going to supposed to make you better so
you're just taking some one component
then imagining this component alone is
good and then critical thinking says
well you need to understand how
everything
fits together
and i think that's why critical thinking
is really hard for technical people
because we learn
by breaking things down and reducing it
to their component pieces but then
putting them back together i think that
part is also there's another part that's
missing from the education right like
how do you see all these things
really working together as a whole and
maybe that's also why we have a hard
time talking with
some business people that do see how all
those things fit together because they
see the big picture
and we want to talk about details and
component pieces and they want to talk
about the entire
entire structure
i like it i like the micro versus the
macro distinction
and
as you were describing that got me
thinking about um
steve levitt uh
freakonomics people i mostly admire and
he talks about his experience and in the
past he right for about three months he
wanted to be a macro economist but he
just couldn't get his brain
working that way and i wonder if that is
the critical thinking but he's really
really good at the analytical thinking
right the more micro stuff
yeah i found when i was studying
i naturally
tended towards the big picture
and i want to see everything as a whole
and see this big story and my professors
are really upset at me because they were
like what are you talking about this
stuff i was talking about combining
evolution and all these different
different perspectives and then they
were like what is this just tell us
about this protein and i was like that's
so boring you can just read that because
it's the introduction to the paper i'm
telling you something really interesting
here like how these things fit together
and they weren't happening so they
really want to see the little individual
components i think that really that's
why for me kind of i put it into that
that model and a lot of my colleagues
that were scientists were very very very
focused on the fine detail things that
they really couldn't get or see why you
want to why you want to make this
connection
i like this idea of
critical thinking and i'm wondering
frank how
like when you're prioritizing things
that you have to do for different
business units or projects that you're
working on how do you
schedule time for actual like critical
thinking and looking at the big picture
uh i mean that's become
to me that is something you have to
practice right
i would assume no matter what size
company you work at or if you work for
yourself
you're
in our society we have a lot of a lot of
meetings back to back right we're always
scheduling time for ourselves to meet
with people to work on a certain project
um
for me over the past few years i feel
like i've been listening to these
thought leaders that make it very
apparent that if you're not scheduling
time for yourself to be thinking about
how the components of your team or the
components of your your stakeholders
problems are going together
uh you're you're always going to be
reacting right you're never going to
produce things that are
truly game changing so for me and
it's been a few years in practice but
i've i've been
very adamant about scheduling time for
myself and making sure that i disconnect
and turn the laptop off
i also do a ton of running um i've been
a runner my whole life
and that hour of my day is super super
important for that critical thinking
right i go out i don't listen to
anything i don't have headphones on so
that's an hour right i'm running through
the woods uh typically right through to
through trail um and i'm not distracted
and that kind of becomes and whether
that's at lunchtime or that's before
work or whether that is at three o'clock
in the afternoon people that i work with
now know that that is a critical part of
my day
but
it's hard right a lot of people don't
have that luxury
i think i've created it over the past
few years
it's really helpful i know that's
something at our studio that we
and
think about a lot is like creating more
focused time for ourselves
and
just talking with different people about
what are their strategies for actually
doing that
when you're just constantly getting like
bombarded by emails or notifications all
the time
i know we're getting to the top of the
hour here so
people have to to jump no worries and
frank if you have to run to another
meeting let me know
i'm rolling into lunch so it's all good
okay well there's a few other questions
so i just want to make sure that none of
them went unanswered but i see there's
an anonymous question here on slido that
is um what do you think is the mental
model underused in the analytical field
such a good question um
i uh
i'm going to preface this with
there is this um
i'm going to say there's this
philosopher derek sivers if anyone knows
him you know why i call him a
philosopher but a big thing for him is
if he's going to a meet-up or an
interview or anything like that he
always tries to get the questions in
advance because he knows that his first
answer is never his best answer
so with that said uh i'm gonna give you
guys the first thing that comes to my
mind um not necessarily my best answer
but uh the the pareto rule
um the 80 20 rule
i i think if you are right coming out of
college day one you're going to join
really any team but for for all intents
and purposes let's say
you're joining a data science team
continuously considering the 80 20 rule
where
80 of your results or your outcomes are
driven by 20 of your effort
is really really powerful
right and i think if you have that 80 20
rule and if you're a team and you can
embrace that you can really start to
understand that let's tie this back to
our last conversation
that
focus time right i need that time off so
i can decompress so when i come back for
the hour of work my mind is there and
i'm in it because it really boils down
to
quality over quantity
right you can work eight hours straight
in a row and after the first two two and
a half hours like quantity of your
work's not going to be great right so if
you can figure out the way to really
rest your brain and identify
that 20 of time um that 20 of your time
if you can make that really really good
and focus is going to drive a really
quality 80 of your your results and
outcomes and i who was it tim ferriss
that even wrote a book based on that
did anyone else have an answer to that
question i would love to hear an
alternative perspective
doesn't have to be now
i was just going to say that or
alternative perspective once we've all
had a chance to think more about it too
can always bring it up next week too
i see one other question that's out
there unless i've missed any so feel
free to jump in live as well but there's
another anonymous question that
is i'm curious about the framework you
use to effectively communicate with your
stakeholders
we have
two that are really effective
uh one is that we have um we as in but
this is this is greater target not just
me and my team now but greater target is
built uh in in-house visualization tool
so similar to domo
but we built it in-house
we use that to
run all of our weekly business reviews
and we we build those in such a way that
makes
right the experience is still a work in
progress my peer that's working on it
every single month like huge new
milestones so scaling up quickly um but
the the functionalities are
uh repeatable across all of our weekly
business reviews so i'd say that that's
big right because like we could have one
leader be in one business review walk
into another one it's the same
experience so that's been huge
um and then the other is that when we do
more technical analytical analysis um in
in
in full transparency my team is still
catching up here but i have a partner
team
that is always delivering their analysis
in our markdowns
and it is target branded and it always
looks the same right so you have your
document you have your table of contents
you have your problem statement at the
top and then you go from there and the
visualizations are really crisp and
clear and sometimes they're plotly so
they're interactive but at first the
stakeholders were like
why not microsoft word like what's going
on here uh but over time right they keep
consistently going back to that r
markdown and delivering in the same way
and now the stakeholders expect
their analysis to look like that so it's
easy for them doing the analysis right
they do their analysis in our they use
our markdown they deliver it and their
stakeholders are expecting that so i'd
say those are the two patterns that i've
seen that work really well
in my experience
uh and it really it feels like it boils
down to consistency
can i jump in for for a second because i
think about the i don't know if it's
really a mental model that's why i
didn't want to say but i think it kind
of because it's something that you just
mentioned it's um it's um design
basically it's good design principles
right so mcdonald's doesn't change its
color or its logo every month because
it's crazy and so we don't think about
that because we're not designers but a
graphic designer gets mental if the
thing is one pixel off right or if this
thing is one shade of blue wrong right
they're just like it cannot it cannot
happen right so by having those
templates and standardized and also if
you think about writing when i teach my
students writing i also think about um
not to make it boring but it has a clear
layout a clear standard what information
goes where and even at the level of the
sentence right so so the whole purpose
is you can ignore
the junk and you focus on things that
are different and you don't have to you
don't have to waste the mental power to
process that and i think that these
design principles i don't know if it's
really a mental model but it's something
that it comes right back to the design
patterns for for designing software
programming that i think
data scientists oftentimes forget about
but those design principles uh are
universal and really good to help focus
on the important things
uh academic papers
right like every action
i know based upon my level of interest
and what i need from it what sections i
need to consume and which ones i don't
it depends it depends if they also knew
that they were supposed to write it in
the proper way
so then you can you can get that's why i
blame the author if it doesn't work
because the structure is there they just
need to use it
frank i know we talked about this
very briefly on a prior
session too but i think even like your
title of director of decision
intelligence says something around the
communication and
was curious if that's something that you
drove to that that title or if that was
um
from target already or how that came to
be yeah uh fantastic question so
um
historically and i say historically
lightly because i've only been on target
for for four years but it was similar in
prior prior roles um
there's this perception that data
teams whether you're data science team
data analytics team right they do
reporting right you do metrics and
reporting you deliver me my reports
uh
my decision to rebrand to decision
intelligence was really to help my
stakeholders change their perspective on
what we do
so i made this was my decision uh i
think like maybe a lot of people i fell
in love with cassie kasarov and her
posts on linkedin and her making friends
with machine learning videos
and i thought oh this really gets the
point across
so i really made the the branding change
to decision intelligence and it has
really helped and when i did that i
started off with all my stakeholders and
i said hey this is what we're doing
we're starting from decisions once we
start from decisions we'll understand
default actions and then we can really
start to back into the numbers and
metrics and models but really i'm coming
me and my data analysts are coming to
the table thinking about the decisions
that you need to make because we know
there's problems that happen every day
we can't really do anything about if we
don't understand what the decisions are
and it was really a reframing of stuff
that we always wanted to do
but really what it has allowed us to do
is have stakeholders and partners that
are now working with us
that are thinking a little more broadly
about the role of data teams
particularly my data team
i love that i see rob you close the loop
yeah yeah
do you close the loop um with
stakeholders who
need
you know your team services you know
following an analysis or what you hand
over with them do you ever actually go
to them and say
hey did you like make a decision based
off of this or did you change
the way that you're doing something
so i i think i'm fortunate in that um
all my stakeholders today i'm
right half of them i'm actually i would
say i'm friends with
so
we're very locked in and i understand as
they make the decision what's happening
so
um i do understand when they actually do
take an action but i'm not really
satisfied with just knowing that they
they took an action what i'm trying to
figure out right now and if anyone has
thoughts on this i'd love to have a
conversation later is um
if you make a prediction that there is a
problem that is going to happen or
service level performance is going to
deteriorate
that prediction is out there you have
stakeholders or operators or whoever
that has access to that information
if you don't know specifically what
they're doing right they could be having
calls with people they could be turning
dials that you don't even know about in
the background
is there a way
that over time you can log your
historical data right your historical
predictions and then over time you can
look at what actually materialized is
there a way
and i i really think it's
regression modeling to say
based upon what we see in these groups
where we are predicting performance
deterioration compared to the whole
we
we can estimate that the predictions are
having the intended effect
right i think it's really comparing a
few different groups there over time as
long as you are cataloging the
predictions you are making
can you formulate that into
um
into a way to quantitatively measure the
impact
so to answer your question number one
in my current situation i'm so looped in
with the stakeholders that yes i know
when they are making decisions number
but
i don't know how to quantitatively
measure it yet which leads to number two
i'm trying to figure out ways to
quantitatively measure it yeah like
weight waste comes to mind in all
functions of work but like specifically
data science like i'm wondering how much
of a concern it is
a viewer is that like your team is
producing stuff for you know outside
stakeholders
and it's either not being used correctly
or not being used at all and like at the
end of the day that's just a waste of
resources and and money and time from
your team
i share that concern
uh you know what i i do share that
concern but it it doesn't stop me right
i know uh
uh i continuously think about
netflix and
um maybe a few years ago reid hastings
said hey our failure rate has to be
higher right we have to if we're if our
failure if our success rate is
is at a certain level that means we're
not taking a big we're not taking big
enough risks if we don't take big enough
risks we're never going to hit the the
next super hit tv show um i know that
some of the stuff we're doing is not
going to get used i hope that it's not
going to get used in the wrong way right
i hope we're we're being proactive and
educative enough that is going to be
used the wrong way
like
i know some stuff's gonna be a waste um
i don't have a great response for how do
i make sure that it's not too
too much
it might be the
part of the answer might be the
relationships you have
you talk about how close those
relationships are with some of the folks
and
so sometimes probably just through
conversation they'll tell you or share
with you that it was valuable
and there's value and it'd be feeling
valuable
in addition to the you know being out
able to actually measure the way you're
attempting to
i think if people keep asking us
to try
right like if you keep getting invited
back there's got to be something there
yeah
i agree
are there
any other questions that we may have
missed or if anybody wants to jump in
with a few final ones
well
thank you so much frank for for joining
and just sharing all your insights with
us
i was going to share the link to your
blog possibly in the chat if that's a
good way for people to get in touch with
you or what's the best way yeah please
do i love i love writing
i don't know if i emphasize that enough
on this call i think it is really
important for data people to write
when you have when you're forced to
write something
it really makes you rethink how your
mind is working um yeah
i would love if people discovered my
blog there and then uh also linkedin
is pretty easy to find me
as long as you're looking for frank
carrigan
rather than francis
awesome thank you so much frank really
appreciate you joining today and thank
you so much everyone else for joining
we'll be here again same time next week
so love to see you there too but have a
great rest of the day everyone
you